d'abord les chiffres ils sont
inquiétants car après les etats-unis la
france est un des pays où le sida
progresse le plus rapidement cette année
on atteindra 2700k l'année prochaine
6200 dans deux ans 14 mille cas le
rythme c'est un doublement tous les dix
mois des personnes atteintes du sida
le mot d'ordre est donc plus que jamais
à la mobilisation sans psychose
mobilisation côté privé un énorme
travail est fait actuellement par les
associations comme l'arcade sida pour
collecter des fonds pour la recherche et
venir en aide aux malades
mobilisation aussi côté public michèle
barzach lance une deuxième campagne
d'information avec un nouveau spot
télévision pour les jeunes une seule
fois suffit pour être contaminé
alors si on veut continuer mais
n'oublions pas le nouveau geste amoureux
le préservatif
il ne passera pas par nous le problème
c'est qu'on organise plus rapidement des
campagnes d'information qu'on ne change
les mentalités
il faut du temps or c'est une véritable
course contre la mort qui a commencé la
responsabilité de chacun est évidemment
engagé